ALS is evil it is 100% fatal usually
within two to five years but the horror
of this disease is the months and years
leading up to the end day by day you
lose your dignity your independence the
ability to move anything but your eyes
and familiy your ability to breathe I
can't speak except through this iPad
Dave Huntley as a former marathon runner
and an Ironman athlete a professor
emeritus at San Diego State University
and a father and husband
in 2013 he is diagnosed with ALS which
is more commonly known as Lou Gehrig's
disease
today I have lost the ability to run
what or even stand I have lost over half
of my breathing capacity and rely on a
feeding tube Huntley wants to try a drug
called GM 604 which might slow the
progress of this disease but there's a
problem
the drug is currently lost in a quagmire
known as the FDA drug approval process
to get a drug approved today it costs
drug companies on average about a
billion dollars it takes about ten years
Starly Coleman is a senior policy
advisor with the Goldwater Institute a
free-market think tank based in Arizona
she helped design a bill that's been
introduced into state legislatures
across the country it's called right to
try right to try is a state laws to give
terminally ill people the ability to go
around the FDA essentially in an effort
to try to save their own lives when you
were in you know a situation where
you've been diagnosed as terminally ill
and none of the treatments that are
available on the market today are
working for you you shouldn't have to
fight the government - this is the most
fundamental Liberty the right to save
your own life the Goldwater Institute
sin ishutin a stunning success so far 23
states have adopted a right to trial on
thirteen more are actively considering
the legislation also there's a national
bill that has already passed the House
and Senate that protects each state's
right to implement these laws the
Goldwater Institute s'right to try
legislation has been successful where
earlier initiatives have failed in part
because it applies only to drugs that
have made it past the first stage of the
FDA approval process so the chance that
these pharmaceuticals would be truly
destructive or increase patient
suffering is greatly diminished one of
them the pieces of right to try is that
you drugs that are eligible for access
under this law have to be going
continuing to go through the FDA
approval process and yet some critics
worried that the effect will be to
provide false hope and they object that
right to try bills often protect
pharmaceutical companies from legal
liability but Dave Huntley argues that
the simple goal is to give him a shot at
living a longer life or being more
comfortable in the time that he has left
without any treatment I will pass in
three to nine months
how is keeping a potentially life-saving
drug from me saving my life a decision
to use an investigational drug to fight
a fatal disease should be between a
patient and his or her doctor
the FDA declined to make someone
available to be interviewed for this
story but provided a written statement
arguing that the agency is already doing
what right to try legislation seeks to
accomplish through what's known as the
expanded access program the FDA
administered process which dates back to
1987 allows pharmaceutical companies to
offer experimental drugs to patients who
have run out of options but Starla
Coleman says the FDA's expanded access
program doesn't go far enough the FDA's
own accelerated approval process
shortens the time window from 10 years
to 7 years for drug approval it just
doesn't work for someone who's in a
terminally ill situation those just
killed you
it takes away everything you care about
one at a time
conversations with my friends colleagues
wife and daughter are a thing of the
past
gm6 so for me failed to stop T
progression to me or it could extend my
life and even restore some of the
function I have lost but at the very
least it gives me something with which
to fight back against this horrendous
disease
you